[Music]
in nope burger news no burger submitted
by McGriddle czar awesome I love
McGriddle my favorite sandwiches from
McDonald's a restaurant has created a
$30 burger with one special ingredient
like truffles or Siham no no baby no $30
that's pretty expensive burger $30 and
it's safe no one has done this and that
I know let me guess San Francisco North
Carolina what enough I know what it is
what is it human meat I believe no no no
it says no one's done this before but I
know that dog they eat it and then they
throw it back up and then you make it oh
that is cream but it's a $30 burger $30
and this burger can only be like you
could only eat it if you enter a raffle
and then there maybe it's super spicy
there's multiple winners a day depending
how long this one ingredient laughs as a
short shelf life not necessarily short
supply supply yeah wanna be like Oh
shrimp burger all like seafood or
something elephant elephants up to
elevate tasks no oh whoa
like speckled with gold you know one of
those gold encrusted thing mm-hmm
let me know what you guys want to know I
wanna know what I know I'll show you a
photo see if you guys can figure it out
tarantula cut it is to just drag a
[ __ ] in there yeah in North
Carolina
Oh what that looks raw I'm not gonna eat
it doesn't even look cooked I'm not
gonna eat it you eat seafood don't you
okay I'm not gonna eat it
what does that mean stations are
essentially insects of the water any he
like Lobster they had the same
exoskeleton very very they're called
bugs for a reason yeah but does it do do
lobsters and those things have hair yeah
yeah I heard that that tastes like a
soft-shell crab because in that things
that's what it is yeah
so skillets and it would probably be
very crunchy and delicious you would try
it
absolutely and although I have had she's
also tarantulas I guess you know we had
the tarantula I had one named Charlie
and the other one named Boris why is he
Russian because he was very um not
friendly oh but but Charlie was a very
very friendly to rent deserts around
they sound like friendly enough friendly
names yeah Boris was a Burmese blue and
he was given to me and he was just he
was just when you would approach his
tank you just trying to be just look at
you so he's not one of those you can
pull out that you just play with not
that one my first one was a desert
tarantula yeah named Charlie they're
cool
she was really really friendly that's
cool I think the reason why I won't eat
a tarantula is because of the fact that
it has nothing to do with all that kind
of jazz has to do with the fact that it
it stings you and kill you no it's not
poisonous most tarantulas are not isn't
that a thing that tarantulas I never
knew they were poison no I never heard
that I think they're trying to force a
fact right now I think just look
intimidating because their fur despite a
lot of people are scared and then you
think about 1% but then if they put the
bun over it you can't really see the
spider you just crunch the spider yeah
if they fried it I'm with you I can't do
it Oh eat a tempura style that one looks
too much like spider they got a bad or
it Ursula's raw yeah yeah yeah yeah like
if it looked like a onion ring idiot
yeah
wait kalila so you had pets two of them
but you would still eat this um I would
eat it just as a novelty just to figure
out if I liked the taste or not I would
eat my pet species I wouldn't eat my
pets pie eat my pet species
dog man yeah I got you know I can't do
that ever
you can't eat dog I wouldn't let your
best friend
yep not those ones my best friend those
ones meatloaf on and bring on the best
friend
like his actual don't guys are my best
friends will eat dog yeah but the thing
is is that that dog that you're eating
could be somebody else's best friend
yeah we eat my dog goby he's not your
best friend if we had beef maybe a party
doesn't eat my dog Toby yeah your dogs
in oh yeah all three of your dogs my dog
see the ollie all three of your dogs
how are you here man you know I would
torture them before you a gouge their
eyes are your master would eat my dog so
I would eat you know I would you out
[ __ ] it that's different
you don't eat my dog I don't need your
dog I wouldn't eat your dog is we're
friends but I'll eat someone else's dog
you'd [ __ ] your food that's true no
you're right I know that's weird guy in
American Pie [ __ ] their food why
wouldn't you do be either I need a dog
man I can I need a dog it's so funny
because before I met kalila I when I see
used to see the dog like in the road I
would speed up I just don't I didn't
know of our pets
I didn't know that you could fall in
love with an animal well I didn't he
didn't have any pets gonna know because
I eat me right yeah so to me it was like
what's the I mean if I eat a cow right
then I should be able to eat a dog
that's in my mind I know yeah but the
thing is is this is that once
kalila introduced me to the relationship
aspect yeah of and that is specific
animal yeah I just can't do it anymore
because humanizing yet you humanize
these animals you and you realize like
when I come home my dog looks at me and
goes oh he looks at me like oh it is no
but when you see you know your cat your
dog they go hi Daddy
you know yeah it oh hey you know and you
do the whole thing you do you know do
all that stuff right but like before I
met you know I used to hit him with
mallets and
you know anything man yeah yeah yeah
liar no I would like to shoot kittens
with BB gun no he wouldn't
yeah what when I was going out I know I
had a BB gun we would shoot kittens in
the face yeah absolutely wouldn't I
wouldn't I mean yeah I could eat fish
I've owned fish I could do all that
stuff but for dogs I think I would be
human before dog cuz I could separate
meat from relationship like instantly so
for example let's say my son grows up
right I'm a little bit older I'm on my
deathbed the world is famished there's
no food it's post-apocalyptic I can be
like hey you know what I'll kill myself
right now you can eat my meat in that
scenario or just kill myself and like go
ahead no now I'm the life my spirit and
my saw has left my body eating me for my
pros okay this is the same discussion
that we have often he says that should
we be stranded on an island and I'd die
first he refuses to eat my meat and that
offends me because I feel like I died
for a reason at least utilize my meat to
get you out of the island that would
that would give honors and I know how to
cook you don't cook we just eat me
sashimi style yeah but what do I start
with your leg or whatever I'm pretty
meeting in the middle just start there
yeah she's giving you like the
instructions and I tell you why why
because what if I'm not horny you still
want to [ __ ] a dead body keep them keep
the this part the lower torso and I
think you're a lot to [ __ ] a dead body
if it'd been [ __ ] it when it's alive
Wow that's my body the way she wants it
to be so I'm gonna [ __ ] it and tell you
start like I don't know decomposing then
I'm not gonna [ __ ] anymore why you
got to even wait till you did just cut
off an arm and eat that together that's
smart that's good buzz in the tape more
energy to heal that arm if you cut it
off they don't want anyone screaming
while I'm eating their arm yeah yeah I
just want to hear that noise yeah but
how you're gonna save all that meat if
they die and it's already like bad me I
wrestle to be just salt it and then
leave it on the Sun for jerky if I'm at
a point where I have to eat my
girlfriend to survive
rather die yeah yeah yeah I'm with you
that's true I'm killing myself because
it's like eat okay so let's say we're on
island right I eat her right we had
children in America that you still
needed to be a father to know yourself
know you better [ __ ] eat me so you
get back to our kids that need you I
come back where's mommy how can you
explain why you rather have him survive
and take care of the kids I mean no I I
just happen to die first I would hope
that he would utilize my meat oh if you
die for it imagine just decomposing and
then him like what a waste
yeah [ __ ] that I even though knowing his
lifestyle and like him let's see it's
reverse would you eat him absolutely you
would yes you are meteor in the middle
that means it would be nice and marbled
yeah so this this island has no crabs or
coconut or anything huh you know what at
that point no I'm going I'm gonna need
more red meat than crab I'm gonna swim
my ass back to another look back home
I'm gonna need your red meats what if we
were shipwrecked right we end up on an
island ieu right yeah and I just go
around the corner and I'm in Maui we've
just gone to the Starbucks or McDonald's
I did it too soon you know I should
explore it a bit yeah that would be a
disaster and they get the explain to the
cops and they eat her why because I was
on a stranded Island
yeah record appraiser like I mean what's
gonna happen to your kids now you're
gonna be in jail right it'll be all over
the news I'd be all over the news
hey think about that man I'm sure you
can catch a pigeon or something that's
exactly one of my things yeah you got it
Isaac naughty I'd eat a human before I'd
eat a pigeon really well in that
circumstance because like so many like
pigeons at Harbor so mean
but you just cook the [ __ ] right
yes got it yeah I have a question Joe
what if my calm right had all the
sustenance so that you would need to
survive Oh a suck your dick like crazy
you would right damn and I wouldn't even
enjoy it it's like I would just be like
no get your nutrients I just be at Stan
you had that you could jack off and at
the very last moment open your mouth you
got to do the whole run for it I'm not
even gonna enjoy it yeah yeah no I'm
just gonna put my hands behind my thing
like this right and so go get your lunch
get your lunch right and just part has
to just you know man
you would do it I would you would you
would ya know about you jump we're on an
island we got to do what we got to do
yeah but that we're Maui and you're
sucking my dick in the cops come what
are you doing
[Music]
[Music]